the murder of george floyd exactly one
year ago today
led to one of the largest protest
movements in u.s history
people crowded into the streets and
demanded racial justice
and police reform president biden called
on congress to take action on police
reform by today in george floyd's name
but negotiations in the senate are stole
democratic senator cory booker of new
jersey joins us now good morning
senator you said meaningful progress is
being made in these negotiations
where the talks stand right now and how
soon can we expect a deal
well we want to get this deal right and
not quick
and i'm very encouraged there's been
hours and hours
every day of of talks and i'm really
hopeful that we can get something done
in the weeks ahead not months
but we're going to continue to work and
there's been a lot of great input from
civil rights organizations
to even national police leadership
everybody feels
i believe a shared commitment to get
something substantive meaningful done
that will create more transparency more
accountability
and when officers do things that are
violative of laws
civil rights constitutional rights that
there's meaningful consequences that
there's
no no one in this country above the law
um
qualified immunity which often protects
officers from being sued in civil court
seems to be one of the sticking points
in the negotiations
is there a compromise between democrats
and republicans on this and do you still
have transparency and accountability
without uh qualified immunity well i
i wish there was just one sticking point
there there are still some gulfs to
bridge
um but i i'm i'm encouraged uh with
senator tim scott who's my republican
counterpart in the senate
negotiating with me that we both have
shared values
we're both african-american men who even
through our lived experience have
very difficult issues in our past with
police officers so we both agree
that the death of george floyd just
highlighted
some of the real problems how can an
officer with that many citizen
complaints
uh be out teaching other officers we
know
that our shared values accountability
and transparency
and consequence when you break laws have
to be the core pillars of this
of this law or it's not worth us doing
something
so i i feel that there's a moment in
history right now the white house
has been extraordinarily helpful the
department of justice police leadership
uh and especially civil rights groups
so again um i know that this is a moment
we haven't had meaningful police reform
uh in this country for decades and there
clearly as we see this drumbeat
of god-awful deaths and violence against
unarmed
african-americans that we all have to
share a collective urgency in this
country
to change laws to expand accountability
and to work
to end a crisis that right here in
washington martin luther king
in his i have a dream speech was
speaking about uh police brutality
the kerner commission and other
commissions decades ago we're pointing
out the very many of the very same
problems we're dealing with now we have
to
do something about this i want to pick
up senator booker what you just said
about you and tim scott
both men of color who have had lived
experiences who have talked about your
encounters with police
how much pressure do you feel either
self-imposed or pressure from the
outside
to get this done this time you know when
george floyd was first murdered
there were calls on both sides everybody
thought this was a moment
finally something will happen and a year
later we are still talking
do you feel a lot of pressure yourself
um i feel the weight of obligation um
i'm going to meet with the floyd family
today he was a son
he was a father he was a brother and
we failed him uh not just derek chauvin
he was to blame but we all are have been
responsible
for having a system in america that has
allowed things like this to happen with
such frequency
and and uh so yes and
you know when when tim and i have been
in private as well as public i think he
gave one of the more meaningful speeches
on race in this country
talking about him as a united states
senator and and his unfortunate
encounters
uh with law enforcement and so we we
we have to make progress here we cannot
lose this moment
millions of americans went out into the
streets in one of the greatest
demonstrations
for justice that we've had in the
history of our nation
i think we need change the federal
government state governments local
police departments
but i feel that and and that's why i'm
working with such determination and
urgency
i heard that part of the negotiations
were taking part in in the strom thurman
room i didn't know
such a thing existed that strikes me as
ironic that you
tim scott uh and other people of color
and negotiating this particular issue
in that room yeah i think that this is
one of those moments in history
uh where uh karen bass myself and tim
were in a room uh named the strom
thurman room the person who has the
record in the senate for the longest
filibuster who was trying to stop civil
rights legislation that eventually
passed
as i sat there i had to note it
to my friends and colleagues that we are
living a moment where never before in
american history have we seen
you know three black men serving at the
same time in the united states senate
two of them uh and irvin warnock is a
part of this but all of us
working so hard to get something done to
begin
uh to make progress again on this
horrible legacy
of systematic uh uh racism and disparate
impact on communities and
so i we have a painful history and
frankly with the continued awful things
from louisiana
and across the country we have a painful
present and we all are invested in in
doing something about it regardless
of what our race or ethnicity we we have
ideals in this country
equal justice under the law liberty and
justice for all
that are not being fulfilled and uh i'm
just i'm just praying that the ark of
the moral universe
uh is bent a little bit more towards
justice through
the labors of folk uh in the senate over
the next
few weeks well you and tim scott on both
sides of the aisle working together
everyone is watching we thank you for
your time this morning
thank you gail thank you enrique